on friday we learned that the u.s postal
service sent letters to more than 40
states
warning that it cannot guarantee that
all ballots
cast by mail for the november election
will arrive in time to be counted
needed funding for the agency died in
failed negotiations over the most recent
coronavirus relief
package and some even suggest the postal
service is being deliberately sabotaged
by president trump
who is promoting the unfounded claim
that widespread
mail-in voting would lead to fraudulent
results
for more on this we're joined now by
michael waldman president
of the nonpartisan brennan center for
justice
at nyu school of law michael welcome
we'll begin right now asking this
question experts are predicting there
there could be as many as
80 million million ballots inundated
election
offices in the next several months and
more than uh
more than doubling the number returned
in the 2016 election just how worrisome
and
how serious a warning is this from the
u.s postal service
well because of the coronavirus we all
have to
vote this year sometimes in new ways and
you're right
many more people will vote by mail than
is usually the case though already about
one in
four people vote in the united states by
mail
but that means state officials and
election officials have to get ready
that means voters need to get their
ballots in early
and we need the post office to do its
job
and not to be sabotaged when
among those who suggested that they're
deliberately sabotaging
the post office is president trump
himself who said the other day
that he didn't want to fund it because
then it would be able to deliver
people's ballots
i will tell you in the history of the
country uh
no president has ever said anything
remotely like that before
okay so michael um if the if the u.s
postal service handled
uh about 40 million ballot mail-in
ballots in 2016 and 80 million are
predictive this year
at the current level of funding how many
do you believe they can reliably handle
well they ought to be able to reliably
handle
the ballots because it's only one ballot
per person
but what they're in the middle of doing
is making changes
to make it harder to deliver those
ballots as we've seen they're
they're scooping up mailboxes all over
the western united states for example
which rely already on vote by mail and
they're all other kinds of changes that
are being suddenly done
at the post office and you know many of
us don't have a view
necessarily of whether these changes
over the long run
are the right or wrong thing but they
are deeply misguided and
very suspicious coming at a moment when
the president who appointed this new
postmaster general
is saying he wants to block it from
delivering ballots to people
we all want to be just how the this
differs from state to state which states
rely more on mail and balloting
well uh seven states this is principally
how they vote that's out in the west
coast mostly
a lot of states have absentee balloting
and to be super clear there's no
difference between absentee ballots
and mail-in ballots there's a lot of
states where you have the ability to do
it but it has not been the case that
people
have needed to do it in such large
numbers uh
and so what states need to do is to
make sure people have the ability to get
those absentee ballots send out the
applications early
let people start sending in the ballots
early
and start counting early the whole goal
is to avoid chaos on election day so we
can have a meaningful and free
and fair and safe election michael is
there any way that the democrats can
sort of seize on the president's words
here at this point
and turn it around in this idea that the
people that rely on the postal service
the most right
now veterans the elderly people in rural
communities
they're the ones that need it the
president isn't funding it is it
something that they can seize on now
well in the last couple of days you're
right it looks like the democrats have
seen
the political power in in making this an
issue they're very alarmed about it i
think genuinely but i think they also
see
that this could backfire rather
dramatically on president trump
already his unfounded
claims of problems with mail-in voting
has led republican voters to pull back
from using something they
always this was never partisan before
now republican voters many of them are
afraid to use mail-in ballots because of
what the president's been claiming
and it's the case that the postal
service has a very
deep involvement in life in america
people rely on it for medication
veterans rely on it elderly people rely
on it
and i don't think people like the idea
that they're
messing with the postal service to try
to make it harder for people to exercise
their
core and basic right to vote i could see
it backfiring
pretty hard on the president all right
michael waldman we appreciate the
insight